I wrote it, I sent it, I'm ****d
- So about 10 years ago,
my writing partner and I
got our first taste of
success and we found out
we were having our movie made.
It was very exciting and the
day after the news came out,
I got an email from a
musician friend, lovely guy.
So this guy had had a
song out, I don't think,
it wasn't like on the
charts, certainly,
but it was being passed
around from our friend group.
When I'd seen him at a
party, I had raved about him,
I love that song.
And he just offered
very generously
to give us the song if we
wanted to put it in the movie.
So instead of just writing
back, thank you so much,
very nice, I was feeling myself.
So I forwarded his email
to my writing partner
and proceeded to make
a lot of fun of him.
This guy's like stalking
us, it's like so disgusting,
give us a minute to enjoy our
success before you're trying
to cram your song
down our throats, man.
Ugh, ugh.
(sigh)
And then I look up and I see
that I have not forwarded it
to my writing partner but in
fact, simply replied to him.
(screaming)
And I pushed back from
my desk and screamed,
"Help me, somebody, help me!"
No one could help me.
I called this gentleman
and I got to him
before he had read the
email and I have to come up
with a cockamamie lie.
Look, I know this is
gonna sound crazy,
but you have to believe
me when I tell you
my writing partner is a monster.
She hates when I discuss
business without her
so I had to make you look bad
in order for her to feel
like it was her idea
to use this song and I
hope you understand that.
I told him, please read
the email, call me back,
you know, as soon as you do.
And I have not heard from him.
Pro tip, if you wanna talk
(bleep) about an email
you've just received, why
not start a new thread,
start fresh.